this baby girl and her two brothers
barely old enough to walk now have no
father
Muhammad takir was a young police
officer from Pakistan's Punjab Province
earning 150 a month he saved and
borrowed eight thousand dollars from
family and friends to pay a trafficker
to smuggle him into Europe
Sunday he drowned along with dozens of
other migrants after a sailboat carrying
them capsized off the coast of southern
Italy
my two brothers set up for Italy the
younger one luckily arrived two months
ago but the Elder of on sale the last
week and drowned it has devastated the
entire family including his two young
sons and his two-month-old daughter
their father was one of up to 40 000
pakistanis who attempt to reach Europe
every year they follow well-traveled and
often deadly human trafficking routes
through turkey and Iran
in the Gujarat District dubbed mini
Norway by local people The Lure of
Europe and its perceived wealth can be
seen in these Villas
left home hoping he would be the one to
lift the family's fortunes
my grandson was very ambitious to travel
to Europe to earn money so he can
support his family unfortunately he died
and it has shattered the whole family
now we're anxiously awaiting to receive
his body
2014 the U.N missing migrants project
says more than 17 000 people have died
in the central Mediterranean
we are facing a huge problem with human
trafficking the mean motivating factors
are extreme poverty unemployment and
competition with other families whose
loved ones left and are sending money
home we are trying our best to track
down these agents who are involved in
the recent incidents in Libya and Italy
some smiling all hopeful this mobile
phone video was taken before the
migrants boarded The Smuggler sailboat
that sank on Sunday
they're asked if they voluntarily accept
the risks
more will be saving to pay the Smugglers
fees and follow focusing only on the
lucky migrants who survived Natasha
grename Al Jazeera